Hãy bắt môi nơi hơi hơi tạng trụ sở chính phụ, thử tương trình phụ phạm bên trứng truyền trí hối nghệ trực đứng với các tình thành phố miền trông
sơ kết chính dịch quan trung thân tốc, sây dân lại, sự trễ nhà ờ cho các hổ dân có nhà bị thiệt hại giống báo
lũ, tại khu vực miền trông.
Giờ báo lũ của nóng anh yên không trăm ha miế lâm, tại các tình thành phố từ quận trị đến lâm đồng góng một nghiên
năm trong trình như bả nhà dân bị sập, quân trôi, phải xây gại và bà miế tương nghiênm bị trăm năm bị trị nhà bị hơi hộng
hại xây chữa, với một điều tích này mỗi hổ dân điều phải có nhà đón tích, thử tương trình phụ đã phát động chính dịch quan trung,
với một điều đến ngày bà mua tháng 12 năm, nhưng không trăm ha miế lâm, hồn thành sự chữa tất cả nhà ờ trong bự dân có nhà
phải xây chữa, đến ngày bà mua tháng mua tháng mua tháng mua tháng 2 sấu, hồn thành xây mới toàn bụ nhà cho ho dân phải xây dân lại.
Hưởng hướng phát động của tụ tương trình phụ các bộ ngành cơ quan đơn vị xuân về vấn nhân dân đã vào cuộc thần đó.
Giờ đó chỉ sau hơn một tháng phát động đến ngày bà mua tháng 12, tại các tình đã hoàn thành sự chữa bà miế tương nghiênm bị chăm năm bị trịnh cân nhà,
đặt một chăm phần chăm một điều để ra. Cùng về đó đã hởi công xây mới, một nghiên năm chăm chỉ mới bình huy nhà,
đặt một chăm phần chăm. Châu đó đã hoàn thành xấu chăm bị miếm huy nhà, đặt 4,5% dân dân dân xây sẽ được hoàn thành trong tháng 1 năm hành hình không chăm ha sấu.
Cái lận hội nghị thuật tương trình phụ phạm miếng chính nhấn mạnh, chính xe quan trung là chính xe không có tương sống nhiều phạm trên tháng.
Chỉ xong một tháng phát động đến ngày cơ bà đã hoàn thành xa đoạn một chăm phần chăm nhà hơi hậu được dựa chữa.
Một chăm phần chăm xuống nhà phạm xe mới đã được hởi công vào hoàn thành 1,5%.
Càng kết sẽ hoàn thành tòan bộ trước ngày hai năm tháng 1 năm hành hình không chăm ha sấu.
Thử tương trình phụ đánh xa cao nhiều dân bộ của phòng bộ công an mà chận tụ cuối Việt Nam các bộ ngày tổ chức chiến trị sá hội,
zơn nghiệp, các miệt là cấp ui chính quyền tán tình thành phố của vực miệng chung đã vào cuộc tế cực với tinh thành tránh giận cao nhất để chính xe quan trung đặt một điều bà đầu.
Chò biết việc chiến khai chính xe quan trung hiện không có khó khăn vướng mắt đáng kể, nên với tinh thành thử tháng xấu lên,
thử tương trình phụ yêu cơ có tình thành phố nhất là các tình đã cắt lắc ra lầy,
quy đồng tổng lực cả hệ thông trính trị. Mà chận tụ cuối Việt Nam các tổ chức trính trị sá hội
xuân nghiệp, nhân dân nhất là lựa cung an của đổi, dân quân tự vệ, đoàn thân nghiênh và cuộc.
Chúng ta hiếc góc sức, phần đầu đến ngày 15 tháng 1 năm hành hình khu trăm hai sấu,
hoàn thành tòan bộ trính xe quan trung, lập thành tích trong người đại hội đàn bộ tòan Quốc là nửa mối muốn.
Tế tư đề nghỉ, cảm chỉ biết thử trụ tích trị ra quy đền, quy đọc thân bộ lực gợt.
Rất đất là vụ vòng.
Các bạn chỉ đạo ngày kì về tăng quân số, tăng quân số tăng lực gợt.
Chúng nhất là hai tình ra lạy và đặc bắt.
Các bạn cảm chỉ chết khai theo đúng cái tình thành đổi đàn là
tự nhiên trên mera vê nhất trên phụ vụ.
Phong ngàn với tình danh là mình biết quân tình vre000 vụ vụ.
Đó cân đấu có có phong ngàn.
Đó là là, một tình thành càng nhất có thể.
Đó là, chúng ta phần đấu h案 thành trước mới lắm.
Thánh bộ này trước đều đàn.
Chúng đồng gia quyết, nếu vật thần quyền thì bóng các chính phụ thụ tự trình phụ gia quyết.
Điều cầu việc khó trọng người dân chủ yếu bằng cải chính,
đàn bảo cơ khai mình và trường lắm vi đều cơ.
Thủ tướng phạm mi chính lâu ý các cơ quan chuyển thông tiếp tục thông tin của vụ động viên
và phụ biến cách làm hai dự quà.
Đông thời phản ánh tinh thần phần khởi của người dân
đạo đồng lực chuyển cảm hứng, nề cả dân tộc sẵn sàng trình khai thần diện lựa quà
nghị quyết đại vụ người bũn cơ đàn.